gentlemen there's a million questions to
talk about with this one but I'm curious
you I'm going to start with you've been
in Wes's like about a countless amount
of West you know movies you've done one
um what is it like before this what is
it like when West wants you to do a
movie is it a text is he calling you is
it like how do you find does he just say
hey I want you to save like these dates
yeah it's kind of it varies I think from
my experience sometimes it'll shoot me
an email and just it'll be somewhat uh
um
unclear but clear enough that it's it's
likely that you may be working together
you know it's but uh it's it's often
like uh what are you doing in in May and
uh
you know it either means you're going to
can or you're you're starting the next
project but it's
what I find a little odd and I guess
some people's you know respond in the
negative but he he's always uncertain as
to whether you will want to work
yeah it's a little bit of Uncertain how
do you feel about yeah I'm playing a
director
yes yeah of course bro yeah yeah I'll
make the time I mean the first time
obviously we didn't have a relationship
and so I yes that's the that's the end
that that takes you to lunch yeah yeah
now it's just a text or anything it's an
email we met I was actually you know my
agent was like you know Wes Anderson has
this piece that he wants you to
you know wants to want you to think
about you you know what you're
interested yeah yeah I feel interested
and uh and he was in Paris and I was
happy I happened to be going to Paris
with my uh my kids like a week after I
got this call
so we had we had lunch at a place on uh
Saint-Germain called the select and we
sat down and and we had a good meal and
he described this idea to me and what
was interesting was that
the character that he wanted me to play
was Loosely based on on Baldwin James
Baldwin little Tennessee Williams he
said AJ Lee was his food critic for the
for the New Yorker but it but the
restaurant was one of Baldwin's Hots
during his time in Paris so it was Wes
is incredibly careful full of care and
consideration in his choices and it may
have been unconscious or subconscious or
conscious but even in that first meeting
there was a bit of information you know
that he was delivering you know about
that uh that I really appreciated I'm so
curious what is you you've obviously
both worked with so many directors what
is Wes like when he's not getting what
he wants is he does he have a
temperature or is it always cool and
collected and what kind of notes does he
give you on set to help you craft that
performance I feel like you've I've
developed a shorthand uh with Wes and I
know that I'm sure Jeffrey understands
what I mean you get a sense very early
on of
his specificity and the writing style
and the uh expectation to adhere to
certain aspects of that style and not
all directors
have that or or
um but but you know going in that you
have to be extremely prepared
um
and Wes is always
cool you know it's it's not it's you
know he's never really
um
no he's never know there's never that
and it's
it's an exploration but we are all
setting out to achieve something very
specific unless uses tools that are very
helpful like an animatic that have
visual
and very detailed
um
aspects of delivery within those so
[Music]
um
once you understand that it's a matter
of building something unique to you and
the character within within that space
and you know another thing that's pretty
evident in his work is Pace you know and
um even from when we started on
Darjeeling many years ago we'd nail a
scene and it would feel great and a lot
of a lot of his work is shot on moving
masters with a very complex elaborate
setups but it's one shot and uh
therefore there's no cutaways and so
that pace is very specific and
um he'd say great we did that uh in a
minute 20 let's see if we can do it in
40. you know and he'd have a stopwatch
going and we'd do the scene again
because that was awesome great 56
seconds let's try it one more time let's
try to get a 40. and if you can get to
40 with all the Beats it's kind of an
amazing thing
yeah I think his you know his his way of
getting what he what he desires what he
envisions is to just keep doing it and
he chooses you know everyone he works
with for very specific reasons he he has
a sense of
of what you're able to do and at times
maybe you think you've gotten there and
he wants you to go a little farther with
it and that's that's cool I love that I
love working with with a director who
has an appreciation for what I do but
wants more of it you know and he pushes
you in the best way in a gentle way to
to get there I mean one of the things
that he's very specific about obviously
is the language and the language has to
be exact
and with
another director I might kind of bristle
at that but his language is specific for
a reason he understands a comma you know
which I just I I Adore that I love that
and so I know if I've shifted something
in a way that doesn't serve the purposes
of the of the language I know that it
doesn't it could be done better and you
start to self-correct yeah that's that's
the crazy thing you understand
implicitly what he's looking for yeah so
a lot of the work is really about the
preparation yeah last thing for you guys
as an individual for each of you uh
obviously I'm looking forward to what if
season two I know you have you can't say
much but what can I get out of here
whatever we can get and also uh the
brutalist I can't wait either yeah so
what can you tease people about it
um
ah just um well Brady Corbett is an
amazing filmmaker I'll tease you that
because he's just the real deal and um
visually it's spectacular but I did this
film uh where I play a
an architect
um
who basically survives the Holocaust and
immigrates to
the United States and tries to start a
life here and uh it's very driven and
it's all the hardships and as you'd
expect of being a Jewish immigrant or an
immigrant in any capacity but um
of that time
um
and uh it's just beautiful it's really
beautifully written it's eloquent it's
very timely and uh
kind of work I I dream to do so yeah I'm
really grateful
to have shot that what can you tease oh
um
there's some stuff coming there's some
uh
yeah more of the same
uh and then some extra
it's a very good answer nice congrats
guys uh I wish you guys nothing but the
best